un village des sciences à la commanderie
de saint quentin en yvelines
un lieu qui n'a pas été choisie au
hasard il permet de mêler la discipline
à la culture tels que la danse ou les
arts visuels
objectif diffuser la connaissance
scientifique et technique
un village des sciences c'est une
réunion en fait deux partenaires
différents partenaires scientifiques et
culturelles diverses
on peut avoir des associations on peut
avoir des scientifiques des artistes qui
du coup qu'ils vont proposer des stands
qui vont être qu'ils vont à proposer
manipulation rencontre discussion jeu
autour de thématiques scientifiques
thématiques et cette année l'observation
scientifique et le rapport de l'homme à
la nature
au programme ateliers autour des
abeilles fabrication de mangeoires à
oiseaux plonger dans les serres de
laboratoire mais aussi danseur virtuel
et ateliers d'écriture avantages du
village des sciences et que ça regroupe
vraiment des thématiques des horizons
vraiment différent pas voir vraiment on
a de l'astronomie juste à côté vous avez
de la botanique vous avez d'une des
associations naturalistes des
entomologistes vous avez vraiment de
tout et vous avez vous avez aussi
justement avec la commande et vous avez
aussi des propositions culturelles et
artistiques
si le public visé est familiale
l'événement est accessible à tous ce
petit grand amateur ou experts les
propos sont vulgarisés il n'y a pas
besoin d'être d'être vraiment un
astronomes professionnels pour venir et
commence à découvrir des choses là
vraiment c'est c'est pour s'adapter à
tout le monde qu'on est con con et de
grandes connaissances scientifiques ou
non et si vous n'êtes pas forcément fait
irruption il ya aussi j'attends des
propositions artistiques et culturelles
qui sont proposés l'événement se
déroulera à la commanderie les 10 et 11
octobre
programme et réservations sur le site
internet